I'm calling this binomial identities the
reason for that is because the way this
works is sort of like trig identities
yeah there's this result and you have to
be able to prove it and go back down
into sort of like your fundamental basic
identities for what these coefficients
are not complete but in the program it's
not it's not called this even though
that's basically what you're doing so
it's more it's more technically known as
relationships monogram shape or you see
relationships between now remember
what's the significance of these NCR's
npr's et cetera for us we're actually
thinking about them we're starting to
stop standard stop we're stopping
thinking about these numbers in
relationship arrangements what do you
cover sheet and we're thinking about it
to do with binomial expansions right and
these numbers what their relationship to
binomial expansion is is they're the
coefficients right so therefore they
call this relationships between binomial
coefficients that's what you'll find
this sort of described as in the program
okay but essentially we're going to
treat them as identities to prove them
right so if you have a look at that
sheet where it starts off at number one
that's just the definition yeah this is
our shorthand way I even showed up in
way of writing in choose R and that is
shorthand for all of this factorial
notation right n factorial
okay so be super careful by the way
because if you're like me when you're
right ends in a hurry ends and ours they
start over really similar to my chart
just be careful so there's the
definition right this is what you can
quote but the rest of it you've got to
bring it back down to this definition or
the primitive you so for instances have
a look at this is one let's have a look
at true
now this identity is really important
and it's really um it's not just
important but it's also valuable to use
it's sort of has a lot a patient's in a
lot of questions right so they're asking
you to prove that n choose R is given
through n choose n - yeah watch out for
those so they had they call this the
equidistant relationship now remember
that this is really about binomial
coefficients and not about arrangements
that's where it comes from a can you see
why this is called the equidistant
relationship you see why because you
know for instance right Oh expansion for
the power of four okay if I was doing a
plus B to the power of four okay start
with the powerful right and then you're
going to go for six four again and back
to one okay
so it's called the equidistant
relationship because which numbers isn't
referring to well for instance these
coefficients here what we actually
establish is that that one is for choose
dot right the degrees after 4 choose 1 4
choose 2 4 2 3 & 4 choose 4 right
so for instance porches 1 & 4 choose 3
they're equidistant from the central
term the middle term of my binomial
expansion okay and I could do it the
center which is not fortress for their
equidistant as well okay so how do we go
about proving it in the same way that
you do like sort of you know trig
identities
you pick one side whichever one makes
more sense and then you were from there
all the way to the other side okay
so which side of it which is that way we
generally go from more complex to less
complex right that's sort of a way that
I brain works so I'm going to go with
the right-hand side I think it makes
more sense all right now be really
careful with your brackets and that kind
of thing as you go from here to what it
actually means in terms of factorial
notation okay so what I've got here
again check for your ends all right
start off there and then let's just
write it down in terms of a factorial so
up on the top
I still have n factorial on the bottom
what do I have
well usually I have this R right which
corresponds to how many I'm choosing out
of it so I'm going to have n minus R
factorial and then I've got sorry I mean
and minus n minus up
okay so because all of this is the
result of known route we've been talking
about this before so it's all about show
demonstrate everything is about this
working this line of working this is a
really critical one where you actually
substitute everything you okay so that's
why you can't take shortcuts here and
that's why the brackets are so important
because you know that this corresponds
to that this corresponds to that this
particular I don't need is pretty easy
proof right that n minus R factorial on
the front of the bonanno is exactly what
we want because when you think about
what this is by definition okay that's
good that's meant to the other
denominator here obviously you've got n
minus n plus R factorial okay I would
really recommend that you put that line
in rather than going straight from here
to I mean clearly at R factorial right
but that line is demonstrating that
you've expanded properly later on when
there are trickier exercises of that
would just stop you from making errors
so that's what we're after which is M
shoes so that's the left hand side and
you can see it's just that first year
trig identity okay so there's my first
example I'm going to show you one more
and then I'm going to let you guys have
a go at the rest 3a okay
it looks really complicated
but again this identity has a special
name it's called Pascal's relationship
now question
can anyone see why this might be called
Pascal's relationship what does this
have to do with Pascal
yeah okay so remember we were talking
about yesterday I think we said that the
whether you build a binomial expansion
and the way you get these numbers right
is exactly the same as how you build
passwords right okay
namely to get subsequent rows for
instance this one right together term in
the zero first second third fourth row
okay fourth row and say the second term
okay what you do is you take the first
and second terms of the third row right
on the previous row so you see how that
relates to this right if I want to work
out okay I said in the fourth row I want
the second term that's 42 okay what you
do is you go to the previous Row Row 3
Row 3 and you Creek well I said terms -
right so you pick term 1 and 2 from the
previous row and they add up and get
that so how do we prove it again
probably make sense to start with the
right-hand side
and again your first step is always just
to without any modification just turn it
all into factorials okay so I'm going to
get this
okay can you see by the way as I'm
writing this out how critically
important it is to get all your brackets
right because just a single minus sign
and everything's thrown out okay now
before I go any further here just like
we treat identities the key to solving
these in the fastest way and getting
from Morgan's cases right head side to
left hand side is to have a clear idea
in your head of where you're headed okay
what's going to be your goal right now
I'm going to want an N factor on the top
and R factorial n minus R factorial on
the bottom because that's what my
left-hand side is equal to right now in
terms of the top leave that one but on
the denominator the deny it is important
to me because I can choose what
denominators I'm going to use when I add
these two fractions together right so
it's going to be in my interest to work
out okay how can i in the quickest way
to turn these two denominators why I'll
grab a sheet before you sit down right
is on the table I want to turn these two
denominators in the quickest way into
this denominator okay so just think
about that
all right before I I do that shifting of
changing but let's just um get rid of
these and get them into a more helpful
water so I've got my n minus 1 on the
top i minus 1 here and you can see here
that minus 1 of that months on Thaegan
cancel yeah something like this put
batters M minus R factorial you're happy
with that so far okay what do I got here
and minus 1 factorial and I'm just going
to rearrange this ever so slightly
because the ends in the odds are the
really important numbers okay
this one this one or that does is shift
you one forward or one vak word in terms
of how big your factorial is okay so
therefore I'm going to rewrite this as n
minus R minus 1 factorial that's a very
minor difference but what it shows is
the difference between this term and
this term
right can you see the connection between
the two okay
there's only one more term from here to
here okay all right now that I can
choose by denominators I want to think
about how do I get closest to this well
the table here I've already got my n
minus R factorial there so that's sweet
this R minus 1 factorial what's the
difference in that and what I'm after
it's just it's just 1 lot of are right
once I put R in the front of here like
so okay that means that this thing
that's R factorial right that would be
10 times 9 factorial 10 factorial
okay in the same way over here okay my R
factorial that's in exactly the right
spot okay so we don't touch it is n
minus R minus 1 factorial I do the same
thing as I do over here right how do I
get this so this I multiplied by n minus
R right so if I slap it in - are there
pop it on the top as well so now this
whole thing here along the end that n
minus R all of it
factorial okay so far so good so what am
I got now I actually have a common
denominator okay
namely R factorial n minus R factorial
good that's exactly what is after okay
all I have my denominator here well I've
got a lot of this factorial and over
here I've got n minus R lots of the same
factorial okay so take my n minus 1
factorial out what left with is R plus n
minus R you can see where this is going
right
okay obviously the art disappears this
end right I'm going to make sure that
I've because again this is a show okay
so I don't want to skip any steps it's
all about demonstrating that I know what
I'm doing so I've run out of space kind
of but you guys keep going down the page
this is n minus 1 factorial times n ok
all over the denominator which is
already in exactly the position that I
wanted to do okay that's in factorial
and I'm finished so to be honest is not
all that much to do here I think these
are easier in some ways and your trig
identities because with the Trinities
often you sort of had to know some bleep
you had to add something and subtract
something or something we which you're
like after you showed it like that's
like supposed to guess that um in these
cases because all about algebra right so
in some ways it's a back it's like going
to teams on T method okay if you have
like a clear idea of where you going
it's pretty simple